vient alors pour savoir si team mérite
de remplacer en cas on va comparer vos
réponses aux avec celle d'en cas dans
l'interview par amour kim est ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à vous déguiser
en elton john ah oui comme encas
incroyable qui met ce que par amour vous
seriez prêt ça vous droguez non comme
encas est-ce que par amour vous auriez
prête à prendre 17 kg qu'est ce qu'elle
a répondu en cas comme qui me l'a dit
alors est ce que vous seriez m à prendre
17 kg pas mon nom comme le cas est-ce
que par aman vous seriez prête attention
tapotage aller vivre à limoges parce
qu'on fait si donc la réponse est donc
oui mon cas c'est un clown vraiment
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
cacher quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer par
amour une somme oui comme en cas
d'ailleurs je crois que l'arm assiste
vraiment à un sans faute je pense que
les a pas de est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à embrasser cent fois ses
chaussettes sales
non non 64 comme en 40 a répondu le mec
qui demande ça il dégage tout de suite
risque car c'est son côté elena
ceausescu est très est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête peu fréquenté les
clubs échangistes vraiment cas c'est
incroyable vraiment on a alors est-ce
que par amour vous soyez prête à devenir
son esclave sexuelle
peut-être à beaucoup mieux en carburant
et bien si on est bien on revient elle
émue elle est d'accord pour classer le
ciel c'est bien correct dans la chanson
c'est important est-ce que par amour ou
soyez prêts ce qui m'a accepté quelques
infidélités mais en tout cinq la notion
de sensibles par amour si vous les
mairies sa peau si ça peut rendre un
réseau de le coupe oui pourquoi pas on
sent la différence entre la vietnamienne
et la roumaine c'est dire qu'en cas
avait répondu jamais et vous vous êtes
prêtre c'est bien vous êtes plus maligne
c'est bien j'ai tout compris vous avez
gardé longtemps votre thierry ardisson
les menus
j'adore